it's life
hey guys I think that so my friend a day
really likes trendy things and he also
really likes cookies and so he came up
with this brilliant idea of having me
make a cookie using all the cookie mixes
I could possibly find so that's what I
did I went out there and I tried to find
as many as I possibly could and these
are the flavors I ended up coming up
with we have the gingerbread cookie
peanut butter cookie chocolate chips
salted caramel which I'm really excited
for and then you have your classic sugar
cookie mix oh my god that like went
straight to my head
oatmeal cookie and then this was a
special one this is pumpkin spice cookie
I didn't even know this existed and then
we have snickerdoodles last one is
double chocolate charm which is a
personal favorite as a total of nine
that's a lot let's go so I put all the
cookie mixes in their own individual
goals we're gonna make all the cookie
mixes first and then we're gonna combine
them all together I don't know what it's
gonna taste like I I think it's just
gonna come out like a like a brown lump
but you know I I hope it tastes better
than it will look oops multitasking to a
new level now to crack some eggs
that's one two three four five six seven
eight nine
let's go I think I'm supposed to mix
these first is it gonna take a long time
just cut this look at this now we're
talking oh yeah I'm so tired
this one has vegetable no I'm putting
this in here we go yeah ooh this is the
sugar cookie mix salted caramel smells
good nice chocolate chip no no there's
pumpkins which I eat it I can't open
this thank you yes look at all the
chocolate chip wow this is this is a lot
of work you know
beautiful it's not so sure oh oh this is
the cinnamon sugar that you're supposed
to row it in at the very end I guess we
could do that for the final cookie look
at out of this dough what's this
oatmeal oh my God we're so close okay
now we're going to put them all in the
big bowl and make our franken cookie
let's go I'm gonna put half of each
because that's way too much batter first
scoop chocolate chip cookie sugar cookie
what is this salted caramel pumpkin
spice flavored cookie look at this color
wow it looks great
gingerbread for that ginger molasses
later oatmeal if you need help you need
some fiber it looks good so far this is
the snickerdoodle if we're gonna cover
it up in a cinnamon sugar how's the
peanut butter you get that extra protein
in there all right last but not least my
favorite chocolate give it that
chocolate undertone all the flavors are
here they're all well bounds that's half
the amount and each packet let's mix it
wait this requires more arm muscle than
I had originally expected look at these
swirls oh my god
oh it actually is a brown color it's
like a coffee it's a nice sort of mocha
it looks like Ben and Jerry's ice cream
it could be a new Ben and Jerry's flavor
no me arms big died
[Music]
now this actually looks really good
today's color looks like a coffee cookie
with chocolate chips and ham oh there's
chunks of chocolate chip in here little
caramel bits and then we're going to add
the cinnamon sugar later I think this is
very well mixed let's scoop it and bake
it set it we don't want to try it
how's it going what are you doing like
what what was the first taste cinnamon
[Music]
so this is the cinnamon sugar from the
snickerdoodle cookie mix we're gonna
roll these into balls and dump it in
here sorry bad word we're gonna scoop
this roll it in the sugar and then we're
gonna bake it here we go oh yeah that's
that it's gonna be very sugary all right
okay let's start with six they actually
don't live that bad okay I'm gonna go
bake these now bye bye so while that's
baking I was thinking it'd be fun if we
made an actual Franken cookie by piecing
little bits of different cookie dough
together so actually look like you know
like Frankenstein but in 54 so I'm just
gonna grab like a little bit of each
type of dough and
make it into little circle shapes like
this and then piece it together into a
bigger cookie all right this one's going
into the oven too
the cookies are here they're done
they're baked they look really good
surprisingly and then they smell really
good
I don't know I would buy this I'm really
curious to know what it tastes like
so yeah let's see all right a day you
made me do this let's put this to the
test excited at the same time all right
Cheers mmm it's gluten so like tasted
peanut butter yeah I can only taste the
peanut butter I think it is very sticker
doodle it is probably because I wrote it
in the end at the is if someone said hey
what couldn't believe it you want and I
say yes this is the taste of yes
are you try the other cookie too hold on
the Frankie cookie
I want you to take a giant bite from
this here we go
I do my bitter to this one I tasted a
different flavor every time I turn so I
guess no matter what in this big cookie
I will have a different taste as opposed
to this one where there's a bunch of
different flavors mixed into one and
it's like playing like could be roulette
like you never know what you're gonna
get alright guys I have no idea what's a
challenging the whip is give me some
suggestions let me know in the comments
below and hopefully she fails at it
because I'm tired of her doing so well
if these cookies like ostrich eggs like
a backhanded compliment alone
[Music]
you